it's racing what I get is a team but I'm
saying it's not Jacob I understand but
it's not think there's a team but you
have to pick your favorite person yeah
based off of something besides the
default location where you're from now I
know there's some crazy outliers out
there just lunatics in the world who
will be from I don't know somewhere in
New Jersey and diehard route for a team
from Dallas Texas sure that's crazy
listen y'all acknowledge that's a crazy
thing but I grew up in Denver and I'm a
49ers fan because your dad went
there so we can live without shoes yeah
very the most
my life's worth more than a piece of
Hill I'll tell you exactly what your
life is would your life is worth $50,000
that's the price you put on it when you
got behind this wheel we're going huh
we're going yeah we're going you're
crazy I'm gonna hit
[Applause]
after Jan Michael Vincent had it all
looks Fame money and incredible talent
what's your name son
British Snyderman where do you live
14:01 are still Avenue pol area 18 he's
not a Hodad squid lips I told you that's
Matt Johnson
[Music]
I'm Jan Michael Vincent keep watching
here with us again
I'd like to be normal
yeah I have this this problem with
alcohol
[Music]
Jan the first time I saw you I was just
a little boy in a movie theater in
Queens
the film was Hooper and I was excited to
see one of my movie heroes Burt Reynolds
how ironic I think the first time I saw
you in that film you were jumping out of
a helicopter
you played sunt meant stuntman ski and
on that jump you landed square in the
middle of my consciousness you had
leading man good looks you were a
heartthrob you could act alongside the
best of them John Wayne Charles Bronson
Rock Hudson and Burt one of your first
breakthrough roles came in 1978 in the
cult serving surfing movie classic big
Wednesday but for me the biggest
impression you made was as the psalm
tortured gifted helicopter pilot
Stringfellow Hawke on TVs air wolf air
wolf was more than a futuristic Halleck
aircraft it was a dragon a mythical
beast that spit bullets instead of fire
and had a terrible boost button and
rotors instead of wings it was a
dangerous creature to be respected and
you along with your trusted co-pilot DOM
were the only two worthy enough to tame
the Beast you used air wolf for good and
Jan you were good
no you were the best
I was too old to care so much about a TV
show I guess I didn't get girls my
friends couldn't stand talking to me cuz
all I did was talk about Airwolf but I
didn't care if no one else got it then
so be it you did a lot of coke and you
drank a lot of booze you lost an eye
you lost a leg but you never lost your
cool I know that you hit the turbo boost
button to heaven and I know Dom has met
you at the pearly gates in his Santini
air jumpsuit and I know that God himself
has asked you to put your jumpsuit back
on and go fly missions and solve crimes
in heaven forever rest in peace Jen put
your demons aside now you've earned it
and while you're up there please say
hello to Burt for me
Jacob Vega - Bulma Deborah hootie-hoo
via Molly malakooti b higher horn who
via kion who cry only Beth Israel
bog Allah movers marne Kirov's
they move ah a man
[Music]
yes Meera Baha u llah male Maya raised
Barack vegetable weight up of vitro mom
redness a hatred of radial a rate halal
hello Schmidty Cuccia bearish who Lila
mean call rahat fateh douche bachata
Danish Mota de miraba palma de mubahala
[Music]
raba min SH Maya the hi I'm Elena
the call Israel reimu amen Oh si Shalom
Cola is well they more men oh yes yes
Oh si Shalom Demi evolve oh yeah Shalom
I'll call this leg
[Music]
it's moved on gone but not forgotten
everybody Jan Michael Vincent Michael
Vincent rest in peace July 15 1945
February 10th 2019 only made anyone else
aware somewhere in the middle of March J
learned about him very recently I mean
still great loss that body had to smell
bad when they found it yeah I mean they
find it Lee was he so removed from
everybody that they found it late off
the grid he must have been off the grid
right J February 10th we heard about
this very recently very recently Jacob
did do you feel like that brought you
some closure I do and I wanted to say
this for the last few days you weren't
here on Monday I wasn't I'm sorry I
can't be there for you when you're
stricken with grief I know the difficult
time bonfire we wanted to do this
yesterday but you know the film crew Z
well we've had to sit Shiva our curtains
closed and this has been a very
emotional moment black Lou and DJ Lou
brought out ties yeah no I want to thank
them both
Christine brought out a veil wore you
Christine looks beautiful or she's just
lost her yeah he goes wow you look
really great Christine I've never
thought you were so attractive huh I
can't see you you really blend into the
wall there Christine you look great like
a Muslim bitch who knows how to keep her
in line Sharia law is hot and joining us
back on the show Julia ger what's up
take our guitar yeah I that up
yeah I said I his lost antler
that girl everybody always thrown a D in
it for years that seems like the one
that would probably the most common most
C so it's not so common but I'm still an
ass yeah and kike that's the other
people flub that one up Jacob a serious
question because I'm curious how long do
you cry when you hear the news I heard
it at work so I kind of had to hold it
together
I mean my partner wallet one of my my
brother texted me say breaking the news
to me
like a family member say are you sitting
down Jacob did you walk into the
bathroom and then walk into a stall and
fall apart
quietly no yeah my brother saw me and
full douche mode one I mean when the
show was on yeah so he knows he watched
the can't you they can't do this moment
was he there for that they can't do this
Oh unfortunately my mom was there for
that brunt of that dude temper tantrum
when the show was canceled I gotta tell
you this I I was born in Israel okay I
am a hardcore Jew yeah I've seen a lot
of yarmulkes in my day but your name is
shortened down from Edgar Berg yes I've
never seen a yarmulke with an air wolf
patch attached to it and by the way
accompanied with an air wolf shirt so
this isn't like a you can't run to a
store and buy these things today yeah
he's not a bandwagon jumper no he's not
even get on it for the sympathy I
mentioned Airwolf on the show I believe
once as a reference to something making
a joke yeah and if Jacob
opened up about his love of the show and
it's real deal the fans of the show the
campers sent Jacob a real pilot script
yeah like in a leather-bound Kate like
original you guys done this script on
the show yeah no that's we recited if
we're going to do alive people would
rather hear it on the radio with lose
man
gonna like listen well guess what we're
casting and we're in the casting process
I think surely could pop up in the
air we'll file it super yeah my
favorite movies and then we'll Jakob you
train wreck
I'm telling you I hadn't heard from him
in years ere wolves cancelled and then
he's a guest on the Howard Stern Show
yeah and a disaster was falling apart
them major accident I think it was early
nineties when he came on early 90s and
he held on till 2019 gotta give
credit where credit is due
he looked like he was 2019 years old but
imagine that look bad when he looks
gassed in the first round but he hangs
in all 12 I was hanging in there just
hope I thought he was gonna turn to a
werewolf eventually yeah sure he was
headed 93 he's running on fumes
he's the menorah of human 2019 finally
gonna be thought that jmv would only
last one more years no when I saw Jacob
in the gear and he and he's made
yarmulkes and I'm like as a program
there's a probe and I mean this is a an
extensive program and we'll put up yeah
black Lou helped out we'll put it up on
at the bonfire
brother Lu it's a funeral show respect
brother black Lou thank you for the work
we have we've all been in that situation
where you're looking at somewhere you're
going yeah I'm going I feel like I'm
being pranked no I'll tell you this your
mom when we had a pardon me for saying
Fattah and here making the program yeah
when Jacob naturally reacted to Airwolf
and I saw the natural reaction I knew it
wasn't yeah I felt it come off
the fans the fans online we're
presenting it with a real like if
somebody with Jacob right now anybody
got eyes on Jacob I more
DMZ
it's about that up your neck jump
it when he goes here wolf thing sprung
out of the sea they didn't they weren't
kidding
some of those campers where the
listeners that were like reaching out
we're not kidding when they were like
hey it's Jacob like cool look is anybody
we should see if he's okay I walked into
Jacobs apartments this him in his
underwear carrying a bottle of whiskey
and he goes what's the point
Jacobs a passionate man which I am
envious of in so many ways very
passionate I saw that NASCAR video
that's exam that was the exact thing I
was gonna bring a skirt now I love my
teams and I'll even like jump up and get
excited but I get it I thought it was
hitting Jacob in the gut in a different
way
that uh you've never felt passionate
like that sounds like a bird I might get
an Eagle logo tattooed on my body and
still it's not that I've ever screamed
like that beyond a roadway but Dan does
have Dude Love tattooed on his back yeah
I got all three I've as mankind can do
love my whole backs Mick Foley it's
beautiful to have a passion for
something like that
and I want to say we lost someone else
important to the show by proxy Mona Oh
Katherine Helmond yeah really
so TV who's the boss I didn't really see
too much about it when did she die did
she die recently when her and Jay
Michael visited a suicide pact oh they
had a meth party with the
DJ booth if we never get super famous we
just do each other in your woods
house time for the off the grid while
meeting wait go up when was it soap
stars 89 motor motor motors dead today
we found out that Angela's mother Mona's
dead and they go yes she was Samantha
you got to fly in for the funeral she
was it was your boss's mom but it was
boner Tony stop calling moto is a great
they they did this in the late 80s early
90s of like the real dick hungry older
ladies like her and Blanche the original
cougar cougar original Cooper yeah
hungry dude someone's gotta come in and
make like a real like a funny sitcom
reboot not reboot what do you call it
when Rose Ann came back really yeah he's
brought it back to bring it back just
like a continuation erection a
resurrection but we're like things
really went like hey well like bad like
who's the boss but you have all the
actors that are in and like Tony
actually got Moana pregnant one night a
weird kid likes it Samantha hasn't
talked to anybody in years Jonathan yeah
you have to bring in the real to those
Jonathan's got AIDS doesn't acknowledge
is homosexuality behind-the-scenes
videos where everyone's actually pretty
freaked out right Danny Patara Fitness
is a crafty and leaves his plate on the
table someone comes they like burns it
with a blowtorch Alyssa Milano
is like do we have to have Katherine's
corpse on properly Nazi Gianna's des
boners
she's like mrs. Bates it's terrifying
please Danza stop because Boehner mr.
Danza where you've been asked by the
crew if you stop it's a shame Corey Haim
more Corey and Corey Feldman really
takes the heat for Tony Danza being the
exact same person just no one pays
attention enough cuz he's not is
flamboyant about it right because Tony
Danza his mind believe people
desperately want to hear him sing
standards not as much as they want to
see tab that sitcom those two sitcom
runs I mean just got him where he can
always walk into Italian restaurant and
talk to a table while standing up hey
guys oh yeah I do remember that yeah
Judd Hirsch good guy for a Jew no horns
the best a guitar you enjoy the bust of
a juice for two years bless the Botti
yeah you gotta try that burrata what a
knob and a half I bet he is swinging a
hammer though huh look at the creases in
those pants all right Lynn watch turn
around quicker look at the crease of
those pants keep flattening out that
means Dick's bang in the front yeah well
that guy gets yelled at a lot a piano
player
hey it might pay for you to film Ivan
yeah I got a piano player with a hook no
anybody can sing if you talk songs
that's what I love I'm going to get
lunch after this and then maybe walk
through a park nothing is worse than
when you miss a package and walk to the
mail off
has anyone seen my other sock
[Laughter]
I saw cloud and it looked like a dragon
oh gotta go shopping it Men's Warehouse
after this boy am I gonna buy some bill
after this Chimel am Babu Babu Babu ah
[Laughter]
my favorite the Vegas guy who talks
between the songs ah look be a lady
how long you two married 40 years a to
die I think he talks to the piano player
at the end you are fine you
that up you it up in the beat
goes try to keep with me try key with me
I'll lead good today give me a hug
adequate at best you know you my
sister's kid which is the reason I'd let
you do this as he's hugging his hands on
her shoulders go get the at last as
you can don't look at the camera thanks
for the break on the piano lessons for
my kid I gotta go hey mommy my kitchen I
like to display all my pans from a thing
that hangs from the ceiling
I like baskets full of seasoning I named
all of my spatulas my wife says that
kitchen
I need a spigot over my stove a center
island would be the dream kitchen issues
wife you can never have enough virgin
olive oil in your carpet at home
[Music]
[Laughter]
fix me an after-dinner drink you Pig you
don't flinch no more with third cousins
it's completely legal did hear you think
you take him totally you thinks a fight
yeah do a dance competition it's not you
got served in a dance competition I can
fake tap dance bear that he could
actually tell if somehow right where I
spit in circles like with my arms flail
like you know like we got do the jazz
finger spirit fingers on the off-chance
I called Fosse fought on the off-chance
that Tony Danza has like a great sense
of humor about himself he doesn't know
okay yeah but I'm saying if he did and
he was able to challenge you in a
tap-dancing competition I wish we get
Mike Mike
Britt on the phone at Caroline's Tony
Danza was at a show on time and he
started asking questions about Alyssa
Milano being hot yeah Tony danza's did
not enjoy that at all and they were
going at it and I was one of my favorite
things ever stories its third hand man
uh third hand it's a second it's right
for Mike yeah was their organ I've heard
it from bunch of people they're pulling
Tony Danza like up the stairs basically
trying to like get him out of there his
people so and they're just going back to
go you he's like you and Tony
is like you say you you
Mike for just goes you Tony Danza
and then he said he just left Mike got
so went on that one you
Tony say you Tony Danza came back
you Mike Brett he goes holy as
a comic it's a show inside a show inside
a show wrapped inside an enigma
[Music]
today's gonna be a little sad it's a
funeral whoa I didn't know you had it on
it holy you got mom yeah he looks
like you guys come foo no quick climb up
the why does the Jackie Chan Wall losing
a master yeah master pow
you could be a Jewish master what do you
say you give me a Jewish master date for
your anti-semitism to come out come on I
slew the day we sit Shiva realized it
wasn't you who brought the tongue did
anybody bring the beef tongue oh yeah
beef tongue yeah you know what's sliced
beef tongue looks like like someone's
slice the whole tongue it's so gross
yeah it's what you think the inside of
your tongue would look like and some of
you have to eat it my grandfather loved
it so Jewish weddings you don't look in
mirrors you just eat a bunch of weird
meats
well sorry meats are good you get a nice
brisket listen you get a corned beef
maybe even for Strom me I'm just saying
someone there is gonna be forget the
tongue I'm used to funerals where you
get hammered and then you just
put a couple crackers in your stomach so
you don't fight a lot so you're not
taking a cut at the priests you touch
those kids yeah why do you hurt those
Garrett boys where are they I know they
just move you from tricks around
spotlight spotlight spotlight I'm Boston
Globe you're a priest spotlight smile I
saw what your benefi no I am NOT oh it's
my life I'm Mark Ruffalo you're pretty
small I yeah
Jewish girls always I think
Jewish there quick first of all which
louse also I think the Jewish people
mourn correctly you're like two weeks
then we drop it it's like then we're
done Irish people are like three years
either I buy it my ex had a friend was
like Greek Orthodox you have to wear the
body like the mother has to wear black
every day the rest of her life
what and the daughter has to wear black
every day until she gets married to
someone it's like bizarre and they just
did it this is a girl who I believe was
like a bj in the back of the cab chick
all of a sudden now is black forever a
few gets married yeah she's permanently
the cure yeah
oh hi didn't see you come in there I'm
Dan Soder I'm big Jay oakerson we're
from the bonfire on Comedy Central radio
sirius XM 95 make sure you watch our
videos every thursday on comedy central
youtube fresh exclusive visual